[Music]
foreign
have you ever heard of the YouTube mom
known as Ruby Frankie well after this
video You're Gonna wish you had enough
now Ruby run the eighth passengers
YouTube channel which was giving out
parenting advice she really was a giver
and she's been accused of giving out a
combination of multiple physical
injuries to her children including
torches starvation and malnutrition that
jeopardizes life and the two women
who've been charged are looking at 1 to
15 years in prison and defying of up to
ten thousand dollars which is a drop in
the ocean for this woman because she has
been making a shitload of money out of
prostituting her children out all over
the Internet pretending to be Mary
[__] Poppins but let's Reserve
judgment she might be innocent you know
when there's a crime committed it's on
the news in the interview the neighbors
and the neighbors are like yeah I would
never have thought you would never have
seen that coming that's not one of these
times this woman had two million YouTube
subscribers doing family Vlogs cooking
advice all of that [__] and there
was a lot of complaints throughout that
time
they're gonna
get a privilege to eat dinner
the privilege to eat dinner bare minimum
we're talking here stuff that the
cavemen probably took care of quite
easily it's not a privilege at this
point is it you [__] [__] what
are you doing over there
you take no texting look at this guy by
the way like there's not a picket of fat
on any of these things and I'm not
saying kids should be fat before you get
me on that one in the comments but come
on like when you're a kid you usually
have a little bit of chubs on you know I
mean he looks like a 14 year old who's
built like a 10 year old what are you
doing over there
you take no texting
Rose here
here I really like you it's one thing
monitoring your kids phones for security
reasons make sure you know no dangerous
things are going on it's not there it's
just mock him at the table at the good
messages he sent these girls are you
ever gonna have a close relationship
with your son you're gonna just ridicule
him for messaging girls and then he
posts it on the internet just to give
everyone else a good laugh number one
Dad yeah certainly pick the good woman
the only downside to giving your kids a
flip phone is I swear I have to remember
how to work it every time I go through
it this is just them being [__]
it's we ain't even got started yet I saw
you in my dreams last night
so the dad's a bit of a dick but we'll
get on to him because he's he's acting
like he had nothing to do with all this
what is the
nature of your relationship with this
individual these are moments I don't
know if you know in Utah they're quite
heavily religious there and they have
quite strict rules and guidance around
what young people can be doing together
so I don't know if this is part of that
but it ain't cool my bedroom was taken
away for seven months and then you give
it back like a couple weeks ago you
can't take a bedroom away you take the
things in the bedroom away what do you
do barricade it I don't think our
viewers know that they're sleeping on a
bean bag I'm sleeping on a bean bag
since October I'm gonna give my room
back like two weeks ago
oh I'll give you the reason why I lost
my bedroom I think so and this is the
reason you can't even remember the
reason it was six months ago that I will
cross a little bit too in the morning
and told them that we're going to
Disneyland and he has to pack see that
is funny you lost your bedroom for six
months for a practical joke and you
gotta admit is a bit all neatly and then
packed all his clothes in the suitcase
and then he walked out the door and I'm
like wrestling he's like what he's all
happy has his sunglasses on it
that is funny you know what right you
can say right the fact that she dishes
out such insane punishments for little
things like that she loves this she
loves punishing like it's a thrill for
her she gets off on it sexually she
probably goes to bed at night and flicks
her being over how much misery she's
inflicting on her children yeah I said
it do you think it's funny because and
then I walk out if you think it's funny
then you that was seven months ago maybe
you need longer without a bedroom oh oh
she's talking her [__] she's like oh you
want some more there's plenty more where
that came from we got more bean bags
[__] he didn't he didn't get anything
he was sleeping on the floor in the
family room so now that the initial
awkward laughs have finished you can see
him staring off into the distance just
miserable because we're seeing one
example of her punishments this kid has
had a lifetime of them and he is [__]
fed up with it Abby we
[Music]
you may never get the phone
back probably not she's just bragging
about the way she keeps her kids in
check and thinking that this makes her a
great mother it's like people who become
obsessed with losing weight like yeah
good A little bit of discipline is a
good thing it's not a competition no I
don't know a friend
you can play with friends no like I
don't have friends I don't have friends
either so both of her kids don't have
friends I mean how come they what kind
of social skills are they getting from
these clumpets if you cut
one more thing in my house
I'm going to take the scissors look at
me and I'm gonna cut its head off
so what are you gonna do are you gonna
cut anything else no we're dealing with
[__] pure evil yeah like imagine
getting your rocks off to do another
little kid you [__] cruel [__] I
just got a text message uh from use
teacher and she said that Eve did not
pack a lunch today and can I bring a
lunch over to the school her teacher is
uncomfortable with her being hungry and
not having a lunch let me foothy all
thing I'm a little bit uncomfortable
with your kids starving to death over
there in the corner and we're talking
about a six-year-old yeah wow I
responded and just said
Eve is responsible for making her
lunches in the morning
no why stop there you know what I mean
when is she going to start paying tax
the lazy little [__] six years old I
can't even imagine having to make my own
lunch at six years old
Jesus it would have just been a box full
of sugar and milk and off to work I go
and the saddest thing is is like I'm
laughing now it just gets [__] darker
and darker hopefully nobody gives her
food and nobody steps in and gives her a
lunch hopefully no one looks after my
kid this is just like the opposite of
everything that you're supposed to say
if
something in the back
in the back out you can pay cash for it
so you learn the value of your items
[Laughter]
it's this loud's face that's just
totally there like it's literally like
who the [__] is my mother Satan
what the [__] am I dealing with yeah or
um you can give
is so sick he's had enough he's
absolutely I know he's like that's just
why won't this [__] just die Dad I'll
let you take the conversation from here
you can do an equivalent value chart to
get it back
and whatever isn't claimed by the end of
the day he looking over his shoulder
like he's Will Smith right now is this
right am I doing it um is this okay that
Dad needs a good [__] hiding man big
time I'm gonna go get dressed for
football
um you're gonna have to go find shorts
oh
oh garden and you are not going anywhere
unless you pick up your junk
if you've got crops drawn all around no
so you see now I'm using bad language
that's how bad of a mood I'm in you get
your socks picked up and don't you leave
your stuff out anymore
right over there run and go pick him up
and then give me 10 push-ups
I really had it good I had it great
honestly wow she's literally like some
sort of drill instructor Forrest Gump
got treated better than this Forest had
a great mother your mama sure does care
about your schooling boy shape your
hands forward there you go
one two down further bring your butt
down
she broke him
and she missed preschool she slept in
and she woke up she's like I'm ready so
I said you know what preschool's over
you sucked through it just to be clear
that that's not her uh 26 year old
daughter going for her job interview
that's her six-year-old daughter going
to Nursery you slept in [__] sort
yourself out the camera's rolling so I
can't get
she's terrifying helps keep me under
control the fact that a woman was able
to post this online for as long as she
did if a man did this he'd have been
locked up after a week she did this for
years I've been a masterful manipulator
I had manipulated using sex I've
manipulated using external rewards I
have wanted something and I'm going to
get it no matter good cart a reference
there from herself a year ago my
daughter was saying her prayers Eve she
was six years old at the time and she
was saying her prayers and she said the
cutest thing I thought it was so cute
and I started laughing she said dear
heavenly father please help me to
survive and I thought it was so cute and
it just took me off guard and I kind of
giggled a little she's literally so
oblivious to what the hell she's putting
her children through that she isn't even
seeing a cry for help in front of her
she thinks that's cute I had a laugh she
said it was funny seeing my any little
baby daughter praying to God to survive
my horrible parenting was funny you
absolute [__]
I'll let that out there that's
so after many of these crazy uploads the
internet came after her they started
reporting her to the police petitions
were signed to try and get Social
Services involved and she was defiant
online who hate me who
would like to cancel me who would
um disappear off the face of the Earth
and I'm not going anywhere well that's
what she thought but also you can see
there she's trying to get sympathy your
actions have caused that and she takes
no responsibility at all she did stop
posting as much because she joined this
business group called connections who
were like giving advice out to women on
how to parent their children and she
became very close friends with a woman
who's a psychologist and I used that
term loosely called Jody Hildebrandt now
Jody has actually been arrested with her
which didn't really make sense at the
start of like why is she also involved
in the abuse of these kids who want her
kids her niece who stayed over at her
house has come forward the thing that
Jody's so good at using what's there
already
because you have so much sin inside of
you oh you you've kissed girls oh my God
you are just Satan himself literally
believed that Satan was working through
me and she literally believed that Jesus
was working through her and
um that she was fighting Satan on a
daily basis not just with me but also
with her clients it's funny if if enough
people paid me to tell them you're not
your problem is ah you're gonna kick
yourself yep Satan uh he's working
through you man uh luckily for you Jesus
is working through me so come on 100
quid we'll sort you out that's what
we're dealing with here that she was
on Earth every day watching fighting
Satan every day must be knocked this is
a Woman by the way who live with Jody
for a whole year and she's seeing a
punch and Satan's facing and I again I
believed all of this so I was like wow
like my aunt's powerful like
like fighting Satan like yeah wow it's
like Tyson and fury to be fair Fury
would have duct Satan we all know that
she had people reporting back to her
anything and everything that I did the
the amount of paranoia and fear that I
had whereas like I I can't talk to
anyone people saw me duct taped people
saw that these things were going on no
one did anything the reason the duct
tape bit is important here is later on
when this all unravels the kids were
found with duct tape on them as well you
wonder where I've been on my Vlogs you
wonder why I left YouTube to save my
kids
no amount of money I and I'm telling you
I was making
Millions
and I left it because my kids were being
hurt
with entitlement they were being hurt
with people's advice and they didn't
have a mother up the front saying I
don't care what the world's opinion is
this is the truth and this is where I
stand and fortunately I had a chance I
had them in my home long enough to do it
and I'm not gonna lose them they're
seeing truth they're accepting truth
they're loving truth
and so this is my passion is to invite
you to stand in truth and put your
opinions to the side for a minute
because your kids are the target of
distortion that is just absolute
nonsense isn't it this is her talking
about the external forces at work and
she has to protect her children from sin
and all of this mimo should just beaten
them up starving them abusing them
where no I don't have any friends
no iPad's no TV that was a little clip
there just stumbled on that one where
we're at it of her little boy and you
can see he can't even make eye contact
he can't even like lift his head up and
speak with confidence because she's just
withering him away from an early age so
all of this is obviously just the tip of
the iceberg like she by her own
admission behaves better on camera but
on August 30th a neighbor near Jody
hildebrand's house had to make a call to
the police tell me exactly what's
happened I just had a 12 year old boy
show up here at my front door asking for
help
and he's uh said he just came from a
neighbor's house and we know there's
been problems at this neighbor's house
he's emaciated he's got tape around his
legs he's hungry and he's thirsty he
asked us to call the police are the
neighbors out of their home or is
anybody looking for him that you can see
uh no we are homes are far enough away
uh I'm not sure her name is Jody
Hildebrand his ankles are taped up and
he won't tell us why
he has duct taped around each ankle
I think he's been
he's going to change his name
he's obviously covered in wounds you can
hear in his voice just even looking at
this little kid is breaking him up
inside because we're talking open wounds
marks on him he's thirsty he's starving
he's been taped like he has been
tortured he is a prisoner who's escaped
he is not just a child anymore both
women were then arrested having been in
the home at the time making videos for
this [__] website they've got
imagine the fact that they were probably
recording advice videos for women on how
to discipline your children well the 12
year old is escaping out the window the
mother's sisters have even come forward
to the news and said we were kept as far
away from those kids as possible we knew
it was weird we just couldn't get
involved because we were told you're not
welcome Child Protective Services also
had been notified multiple times about
this over the years and they failed
these kids they've actually postponed
the bail hearing because there's so much
evidence on them because this woman was
bragging about what a great mother she
was she's actually snitched on herself
so much I guess you could say that if
you're ever wanting to know how not to
be a criminal don't snitch on yourself
online and then don't make courses about
it because you will end up in jail so
since all this uh the cops have
obviously found all the other children
recognize that this has been an issue
throughout her parenting among all the
children and luckily they've apprehended
us she ain't got her kids anymore she's
behind bars now the question I asked
earlier was where the hell is the dad in
all of this well you can ask his lawyer
because he's not talking sounds innocent
am I right he's uh busy he's struggling
uh trying to make sense out of what's
happened to him in the last 13 months
and
uh kind of coming out of a fog just a
hazy fog which I've not got a great
recollection of so in other words he was
completely taken off guard by these
allegations completely shocked
absolutely shocked chocolate did nothing
sooner literally they're your kids
you're in all the videos bro she hadn't
reached out to him for months and months
and months before that
she reached out to him when it was an
emergency knowing she could rely on him
to help his kids sorry we're hearing now
that they had no contact for months and
months apparently right
they were separated I read for 13 months
so they weren't living with each other
how much was he seeing the kids
uh almost not at all actually not at all
so this is your defense you separated
with a you didn't see the kids at all
and she was just allowed to do whatever
she wanted and you weren't on the wiser
why is that because she told him it was
better that they needed to work on their
marriage and needed to keep their family
together but that everything was better
off with him not in the home we need to
work on our marriage by having nothing
to do with each other we wouldn't keep
our family together by never seeing you
well this makes sense why were they
separated what was the catalyst
oh I probably shouldn't go into that
that's that's pretty private yeah that's
private these [__] are all over
the news for abusing children privacy
went out the window a while ago this
whole defense of his that she's just
manipulated him and he was a defenseless
little animal who just helplessly
couldn't see his children all that time
when we've seen him in the videos
perpetuating the same kind of behavior
that she was and now all of a sudden he
had no idea and he wasn't even there and
you know it was best for the kids if I'm
just not there conveniently to exonerate
himself it just doesn't add up man it's
[__] he's actually more pathetic
than her so that's where we're at now in
the case it is ongoing and I'm gonna
follow this one because I really hate
this woman let me know what your
theories are in the comments you little
investigative journalists out there uh
hit that like button stay subscribe to
the true Geordie YouTube channel for
more and I'll see us on the next one